welcome to the david pakman show i am
fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman today and you know what we've got
a lot to talk about so let's just hop
right into it first and foremost let's
talk about the midterms because we do
have a very important day coming up very
soon
and that is labor day
and
typically in election years once you hit
that labor day mark everybody
switches into general election
mode so if you're already
tired of midterm news
then i am very sorry because there's
going to be a lot coming out once we hit
labor day in just a couple weeks here
but
right now
and this honestly is super astonishing i
love to see it though
democrats are looking pretty good
right generic ballot polling actually
has them up against republicans in house
races the senate now looks like it's
firmly going to be in democratic control
to the point where we may not even have
to worry about people like joe manchin
or kirsten cinema for the next two years
things are looking pretty darn good
you've got the post row bump
you've got the inflation reduction act
gas prices are coming down inflation
coming down a little still really bad
unemployment numbers look good on paper
but
there is one thing
republicans have going for them right
now
and that of course is donald trump's
post fbi raid
poll bounce
now i use the term raid
not because i'm you know
agreeing it was a raid but because
that's a lot easier than saying the
fbi's execution of the search warrant at
mar-a-lago so please understand when i
use the word raid what i mean is the
lawful execution of the search warrant
down at mar-a-lago
but
his poll numbers have gotten a bounce
from that
and of course ron desantis's poll
numbers have actually gone down
since the fbi went down to mar-a-lago
and
if that republican anger holds
republicans may do better in this year's
midterm elections
or at least that's the prevailing theory
right
we have seen republicans postulate this
cassidy hutchinson of course who was one
of the star witnesses
of the january 6 committee over the
summer came out the day after
and said well you just handed the
midterms to the republicans
don't agree
because see there's a big difference
what's happening with the democrats
right now
is that
you have anger
over roe versus wade getting overturned
you have anger
at january 6th
you have the lingering threat of
authoritarianism
coming from all of these
republican-controlled states
taking away rights of certain groups of
individuals state by state
all of that
has angered democratic voters
but more importantly it has energized
them
compare that to what's on the other side
oh we're so mad at the fbi right now
cool
you're going to be mad in a week
you're going to be mad in two weeks
and by the way the funniest part about
that
is a lot of that anger already had
subsided i'm not saying all of it did
because you still have you know the
people out there threatening the lives
of fbi agents threatening the lives of
merrick garland and other members of the
doj the magistrate judge reinhardt
but
the anger had already started to subside
by the time we learned that donald trump
likely had classified nuclear documents
down there at mar-a-lago
majority of independents
support the raid majority of democrats
obviously do republicans
only about half right at i think 50
percent
are opposed to the raid
so even if the republicans by virtue of
trump
got a bounce in the polls which trump
did
i don't know that that anger carries
right you've got the front page or cover
story really of newsweek right now
talking about this post-raid bounce is
this enough to push republicans over the
edge uh no
no it isn't not even close
because the more that comes out about it
the worse it looks for donald trump
now i will give trump credit which is
not something i ever do but i will give
him credit last week
for kind of backing the doj into a
corner
by calling for the release of the
affidavit you know let us see all the
evidence you have including the name of
the leaker
so that we can clear all this up with
the public
well whoever was advising him to do that
clearly understood that the doj can't do
that
you know not only
would they put lives unnecessarily at
risk because we've all seen the threats
coming from trump's supporters
but it also could impede the actual
investigation itself
if we release this
you'd get the names of individuals
cooperating you might get the names of
other targets
you might get more information that
could lead to the destruction of
evidence and we cannot do that
in fact the doj actually came out
within the last couple days
and admitted part of the reason we don't
want to release this is actually to
protect
you
donald trump
but the reason i say that that kind of
backed the doj into a corner is because
trump called for the release he knew
they couldn't do it
so once they say no we can't he goes aha
i gotcha i knew all this was phony
otherwise you'd release it and his
supporters including you know plenty of
people in right-wing media
also jumped on that messaging saying
obviously it's fake
and the reason they're jumping on that
messaging
is because they want to get that bounce
back
they want to make sure that those
positive
poll developments that they have seen
since the search of mar-a-lago they want
to make sure that they hold on to the
midterms
so they want to keep talking about it
because they think it's going to help
republicans in november
but in reality
what it's going to do
is it's further going to energize
democrats and it's going to turn
independence away from the republican
party
so they're stuck between a rock and a
hard place right
they want to talk about it because they
think it helps with the republican base
but at the same time the more they talk
about it the more it's going to turn off
independence
neither party in this country
can win elections maybe win some
primaries obviously
but you can't win a general election
if you do not attract those
middle-of-the-road moderate independent
voters you simply cannot the numbers are
not there
so the more republicans talk about it
the worse their poll numbers ultimately
are going to get
they may have gotten that little bitty
bounce right now
but it's not a type of anger that is
sustainable
certainly not in a year when trump isn't
even on the ballot
you know if this was 2024 and this
happened and trump was running that
would help all republicans
but he's not on the ballot this year
so i don't know what the republican
strategy here is
but i do know
with pretty much certainty
that it definitely is not working for
them
one of our sponsors is xebiotix a
probiotic drink that breaks down the
byproduct of alcohol which is most
responsible for some of those rough
mornings if you drink a small bottle of
zebiotics before your first drink of
alcohol and then drink responsibly guys
please get a good night's sleep you can
enjoy the next day feeling refreshed and
ready to make the most of it sam cedar
swears by it here's how it works when
you drink a toxic byproduct of alcohol
builds up in your unprepared gut
this byproduct causes you to feel
terrible the day after drinking
z-biotics produces an enzyme like the
one your liver uses to break down the
by-product and z-biotics is fda
compliant for safety this is a product
for responsible adults who have just a
few drinks but they have plans tomorrow
they want to feel their best we all want
to feel our best if z-biotics doesn't
work for you you get your money back
guys it's that simple
go to zbiotics.com
pacman and use the code pacman for 15
off your first order the link is down
below